what's your reaction to the idea that no
other element matters in a story if
there's no conflict
I think that is very true
I think people misunderstand conflict
conflict doesn't have to be people
punching each other in the face on the
boardwalk as I used to say
you know as conflict is person versus
time person versus the vision of
themselves their vision of themselves
versus the reality of being themselves
some of the greatest movies I've ever
seen the conflict is so subtle that you
can't even identify the villain
it's just a person versus time
you know
so yeah I would say that that's an
accurate statement
how do you create conflict
um create conflict is uh as
Jen grasanti uh I don't know if you've
ever interviewed her before I love her
she's amazing she's wonderful but she
talks a lot about wounds the character's
wounds and those identify the things
that they are dealing with and coping
with even now about how do I how do I
resolve this thing that happened to me
so long ago that it's practically in My
DNA
and conflict is about what that person
cares about putting behind them
and it's like sure it's sure it's the
guy who shot my paw but it's also
you know I'm gonna lose my house if I
can't come up with
two thousand dollars to pay back taxes
or like some other thing there are some
things that are more visually
interesting than others
but good good conflict can be defined in
a much broader way than I think most
people think about it
what is Meaningful conflict versus
conflict that doesn't matter
uh for me meaningful conflict is
something that is something that
resonates with the character
individually
like a Bond film is a totally different
thing it's like if I don't go here these
missiles are going to do this that
everybody's going to die
that bores me to death because I've seen
it
I've seen it seen it and seen it again
and what matters to him personally
is very rarely on screen
like sometimes you know it's you know
his daughter that he doesn't know is his
daughter or whatever the plot of
the last Bond film was but
it's
if it's not organic to the person
and their history and their life it
doesn't register to me
it's the it's the authenticity of that
conflict we all understand what it is to
be emotionally connected to something
but just like some Relentless
unmotivated bad guy that has to be
stopped is not
super interesting and you very rarely
walk out of a theater like crying
because of the resolution to a conflict
that involves somebody who's that cut
and dried
well some of the best villains though
are ones that don't reveal themselves
right first you know
well every Darren arnofsky film that's
ever been made is always got a huge
element of personal conflict in there
which is why they work most of the time
what do people get wrong about conflict
people get wrong uh in thinking the
conflict has to be noisy and easily uh
and easily registers
it's very easy to put two people in a
situation where they argue and then it
escalates into this terrible thing
but if there's some kind of a history
there and some kind of a wound that is
motivating everything I think that's
much better quality conflict
what if someone gets a note
that says there's not enough conflict
well
that's a tough one it usually comes in
the guise of uh like what are this what
are the stakes all Stakes really are is
the sense that there is conflict that
needs to be resolved
um so Stakes you know it's a very
complicated note to get stakes in one
word because you have to figure out how
to make it personally important to
somebody and that's when you have to go
back in and do the interview where
someone has to give you a bite like
you know I entered this thing three
years ago and I lost and it's just I'm
not going to lose it this year to this
person who's going to do this for the
first time
and then all of a sudden it's like oh
we've we've taken what's at stake for
that person individually into account
making that conflict personal and we all
know what it is to feel like to lose to
somebody we don't like who doesn't have
a history
every everybody I know has one story
about some unqualified person that
leapfrogged over them and got a job
that's personal that matters
this is an example
sure can you illustrate for us through
your work ways to build conflict I I
talked about it earlier in the interview
with flipping out as the great example
with Jeff Lewis who I adore he is a
wonderful person with a great
personality
but again his OCD presented a lot of
challenges and it was important that we
set that up but we can't just have a guy
sit down and say well you know I'm very
hard to please because I'm very specific
about things so there were lots of
little things in the episode he turns to
somebody who's working for him and he
says you're picking up the lunch order
yes okay two things no onions
and to drink I want 85 Sprite 10 fruit
punch five percent this if they don't
have Sprite I want 80 this 20 this and
five percent this
and it's like you see I Who on Earth is
precise about basically making a suicide
which is what we called when I was a kid
which is just
run up and just put the little Mountain
Dew in this and a little fruit punch and
a little this and you've created
something he's so precise about what he
wants
that there is no logical reason why his
needs can't be fulfilled
the conflict is within him because he
can't be happy until things go exactly
according to the way he wants them to go
and that helps you identify with him and
his conflict and more than once you'll
look at the TV and go like why can't you
just do what he asked you to do
like when something goes wrong even when
you would imagine that he's going to be
the villain you're like he just all he
wants is this thing
you know why is it so hard for him to
have what he wants
which is a whole other
whole other deal but
that's why that's why I think you know
personal conflict is a
is important because you know he doesn't
want to be yelling at people it's just a
byproduct of him not being able to have
the basically very simple thing that he
could have if the world paid attention
to instructions or anybody listened to
him
sure so you're setting up these little
sort of landmines not not the big ones
but just little baby ones going forward
yes and those things all escalate
because there's going to be a time where
what he wants matters
and he's not going to get it and it's
going to be the worst thing that ever
happened
hence he'll flip out yeah
yeah and so is the audience invested in
oh here's the little one okay and then
it's going to get bigger if you don't if
you don't have a villain that you can
identify with and this is this is where
the Bond films have been right for a
long time is there's always some
motivation that the villain has for
being the villain
like well you know this happened to me
and my vision of the world is like this
because that would resolve the problem
that I see in the world
and you can identify with them because
you understand like yes they're Maniacs
that want to blow everything up but they
want to blow it up because there's
something that happened to them
and that they can't get through unless
they wipe life off of this island or
whatever his motivation is
that works because you feel for this
villain like here is a here is a wounded
person
who is trying to get through life like
we all are
they're just doing it in a really
hazardous and crappy scary way